honesty really really matters and i
think much of the reason why i started
this podcast was to give
the world the much needed honesty it
needs but often doesn't get
you hear success stories that are
glamorized and that are oversimplified
but
that's rarely rarely the case this
week's guest
will give you exactly that raw
unfiltered honesty
like you've never heard it before and in
some points honestly that might make you
a little bit uncomfortable
it made her uncomfortable it made me
uncomfortable this week i'm joined by
chrissy
chella she's an unbelievable and in my
opinion
heavily underrated entrepreneur running
multiple
multi-million pound businesses she's one
of the
uk's number one fitness creators
athletes whatever you want to call her
she's an author her book is coming out
in january
she has a remarkable story one that
starts from very very humble
beginnings as an immigrant that was
bullied on the playground in the uk
and what you'll find out about her is
inspiring it's captivating
it's real one of the most amazing
conversations i've ever had on this
podcast
and i'm so glad that we can bring you
her story
in this way told with total honesty
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire rover ceo
i hope nobody is listening but if you
are then please keep this to yourself
as i did a little bit of research on you
and i got to
sort of uncover your story and i got to
stalk you a little bit on social media
um the more and more that i observed and
sort of looked
past your instagram feed the more
i saw a pretty remarkable
entrepreneur and business person and one
of the thoughts that came to my mind and
you know this podcast is all about
speaking the truth and being honest was
this question which is
do you think that you get the credit you
deserve
as an entrepreneur that's the question
um it's not about me i haven't built a
community about me i've built a
community about
helping other women and i think that
it's never fully been about me and
the credit that i get is seeing other
women
thrive and succeed and come together
and that for me is enough credit i don't
need an award i don't need someone to
say oh my god you're the best business
woman in the world
for me when i see or when i read another
woman's story
that for me is enough i don't need
anything else
so yeah i do so because i was when i i
was watching some of your stories on
instagram
and you you run an office right
of people you run multiple businesses
right
and i typically think that people
are very very quick to arrive at
judgement when they see
a pretty young lady who's worked out on
instagram who has a big following
and they t and this is just being
completely honest they tend to come to
judgments very quickly a conclusion a
conclusion yeah and that that
conclusion and that narrative or that
image that they form of that person
i've come to learn is usually severely
wrong
100 it is and you know it's funny you
say that because i've also been on
multiple dates with people
and you know they see my instagram
following and they automatically assume
that oh it's because you get your ass
out that's that's
that's why you make money or it's
because you get your ass out that's why
you've built what you've built
and the truth is if i did that and if
that was the
fundamental reason then i wouldn't have
a team of 30 people
in one company and building another
company that sells out every time we
restock
it goes past being a pretty face or a
pretty picture
it goes past being a nice body it's
about the message that you have it's
about what you want to
truly truly put out in the world and i
think if people make that conclusion
it says more about them than it does to
me does it make you feel though
and i want you to be really honest here
how does it make you feel i think
okay like i'm gonna be complete honestly
i think it's one thing to be judged and
it's another thing to be judged as a
woman
okay so why is it that when you see a
handsome man
you don't come to a conclusion that he
only got what he got because he's
handsome
why is that as a woman i have to justify
myself more
i have to explain myself more all the
time
it's draining i shouldn't have to
explain myself
my face my body all of this stuff it's
just
external you know and
i think that can i swear on this
question
i smell my youtube all the time some
people get offended and i'm like listen
this is this is who i am
something else yeah no it pisses me off
it
pisses me off but at the same time it's
like it feeds me
right you know it feeds me like piss me
off even more because that's how i
thrive you you saying to me i can't do
something you saying to me that i only
got there because of this and that
it pushes me more to achieve more
and yeah i mean it's their problem not
mine i guess
there's a lot of you know let's just for
a second imagine that
that judgment of you was correct and
that you'd got here because you were
pretty or whatever or you're
you know you have a great physique or
whatever it was
um what would they be missing what is
the truth why why
did you get here because there are lots
of very pretty people out there right
yeah um but for some reason you made it
here and
i've seen your businesses i've looked
into them you have
pretty phenomenal businesses and you're
running big teams of people in big
offices so
like there's two kind of thoughts to
this but i think the central question
that i'm trying to
answer for myself is what is it about
chrissy
that differentiated you your approach
your message and the way that you
connect with people
from all of these other people that are
trying to do what you're doing
i think in all honesty if i'm if i'm
answering that question from a personal
perspective
i've always been 100 honest and
transparent with who i am
you're not gonna find a hidden secret or
some nasty surprise like
this is who i am you literally either
take it
or you leave it and i'm not going to try
and be anything else
to fit in for anybody else you know
and for me when i started my fitness
journey when i
you know moved countries to england i
never felt like i had a sense of home
i never felt like anybody understood me
so to be blessed with a platform where i
can build a community
and bring women together globally you
know this is this goes beyond
me this is about bringing women together
that have
been abused that have had you know
mental
disorders eating disorders such bad
things you couldn't even imagine what
women have gone through and have told me
to bring them all together and to create
this
tribe you know that for me
is like i think that's what people see
yeah and i think that's what people
believe i want to do because i genuinely
do want to do that
and you know one of the things that
sorry to interrupt there but i really
wanted to
one of the things you said was about you
being yourself
and i asked you that question actually
with
a bit of a preconceived idea of what the
answer would be and
when i watch you on instagram the feel
that i get from you versus
pretty much everybody else other than
one other person i've got to be honest
and he sat
in this chair and he's actually coming
back is joe wicks like when i met joix
he is the guy you meet off off
off air or whatever is the same guy and
he's so [ __ ] genuine
and all he cares about is like genuinely
helping people but the reason i said to
joe i said i think the reason you're so
successful
is because you are yourself and
you will share it all and when i was
watching you on instagram and watching
some of your videos
you cater to the 99 of people's lives
which is the
real [ __ ] yeah i saw your video this
week you did on your story
you're waking up and you're saying
listen i don't want to wake up today and
most people don't admit that because you
know a lack of perfection is sometimes
perceived as weakness so
i wondered how that resonated with you
in terms of the importance of
your success originating from chrissy
being her truer self
yeah you're you can only be the best
version of yourself right
and i think if you start trying to be
something else soon enough it will come
out
or you'll start to fall through the
cracks or it will slip
something will slip and you can only
uphold that image and
you know that presence for so long
before it really just [ __ ] up
so the only thing you can do is be the
best version of yourself
and this is what i tell people all the
time it's never been about other
people's perceptions of you
it's always been what you think about
yourself and if you
truly truly believe in yourself
you won't want to be anybody else you
want to you won't want to be fake you
wouldn't want to be
trying to please everyone my job isn't
to please everyone were you always at
that point
no tell me about that oh my god no i
mean
i remember when i was in a relationship
i was 16 years old i was like i'm gonna
marry this person i'm so in love
like this is it uh and then he cheated
on me and i was like oh [ __ ] this is not
it it's his name
no he does not deserve the air time i'll
tell you that much
but i was heartbroken and
i was trying so hard to please this
person
you know i was trying so hard even in
school i know it sounds petty but i was
trying so hard to fit in
all the time all the time
i remember like this is so this is not
cute on my end i'ma be honest with you
i remember being at school and i'm
foreign okay like
i'm mediterranean we're hairy okay
and i had a no i had a moustache and the
girls used to rip me for it
and i was so sad i was like oh my god
why am i not like
these pretty english girls like i don't
understand like i used to feel so shitty
about myself
constantly trying to like fit in and
then when i got cheated on i was like oh
my god
it must be because i'm not pretty enough
it must be because i'm not sexy enough
[ __ ] that that's draining what do you
mean i constantly have to be something
else for someone else
i'm never gonna be happy and i i wasn't
happy for such a long time
so yeah i just i just fully like expose
my moustache story there
so let's take us from mustache to
self-confidence
um what was that journey and what
changed your uh
your your self-esteem and your
self-confidence what helped you
get that confidence in yourself i think
for me it was can we just i think that
should be the podcast title master
no no seriously even sarah doesn't know
that
i used to have him no guys i'm gonna be
honest with you okay
like i don't give a [ __ ] i had a
moustache growing up
okay and all the girls used to rip me
the [ __ ] up they used to be like uh
your man your boy like honestly
[ __ ] [ __ ] man and i ate my school
dinner
for six months in a toilet because i
didn't have any friends
do you think that experience is part of
the reason you are who you are today
100 like honestly
it's pretty impossible to to break me
and when you've broken me understand
that you've really
like broken me down because it takes a
lot now
was that we talk about the mustaf
mustache thing is if it was
this trivial thing but i'm guessing what
you're saying is you were bullied in
school
yeah but at the same time it's not like
i was constantly bullied like i think
i don't know a lot of us go through
awkward stages in school trying to make
friends trying to be with a cool gang
trying to do this try and do that then
you almost become
like mean as well because you're so hurt
by everybody else that
you only yeah so
i think you know like i remember
walking into sixth form one time and a
lot of personal things
happened in my life and no one wanted to
be around me at that point
and i just hated everyone around me
and i was full of anger constant anger
and hate
you know and i didn't want to be that
person anymore especially after being
cheated on i didn't want to be that
person anymore
and i remember being on the train one
day
because i used to work in potter's bar
at the time um
in this little men's boutique like
retail shop and i was coming back home
and i remember like the penny dropped
and i was like
i can try so hard to be sexy and cool
and all this stuff
other people but i'm not doing anything
for myself
and that's where the quote do this for
you comes from
because i signed up to the gym that day
and then i'll walk straight back out and
then go back for two months i'm not
gonna
lie to you i was signed up and like i'm
gonna do this i'm gonna do this i know
what to do
signed up didn't come back for two
months i was actually actually hanging
back i don't know what to do
why didn't you go because i was scared i
was like who i was like who do you
who do you think you are crazy trying to
be like
a fitness girl you don't know what
you're doing you know
this was like six years ago you don't
know what you're doing
go back home relax right relax chill go
to work
study relax at some point you must have
changed your mind
yeah i did i did and evidently i did and
i was like uh
okay now i need to do this like what am
i doing i'm
so lethargic i'm tired all the time i'm
not strong
i was never like um overweight or
underweight i was just
tired all the time and drained
especially mentally
so when i got into the gym i remember
looking at the leg press machine and i
was like
what is this transformer i don't know
what the [ __ ] to do with this machine
and everybody else around me seemed to
kind of
know what to do and then there was like
men there
and the women were on the cardio
machines and the men were at the weights
i didn't care about the cardio machine i
was so intrigued by the weights
i was like what why do men go there what
is that about
men that go there and women go there i
want to go there
and i didn't know how to use weights i
didn't know what i was doing i was
training
i didn't have anything like no one was
on instagram at the time
no one was teaching the way social media
has literally opened up a book full of
information
and free content and we didn't have that
at the time i started you know i didn't
know what i was doing it's how did you
i learned you learned i just learned i
just was like
you know what i'm just going to do this
and i kind of i kind of got addicted to
the feeling of
how completing a workout made me feel
and i started going again and again and
i started learning because what was it
doing for you going
it was giving me my therapy therapy
from what from life from
my reality from the fact that i
was so depressed or with who i was and
so angry at the world
and everything the world had done to me
and the only time i felt like i could
escape
was at the gym which is so crazy
because the gym is like a chore for
people i've got a [ __ ] train today
but i went there and i escaped
it was therapy and no one could take
that feeling away from me
not an ex-boyfriend that cheated on me
not a mean girl at school
not a horrible boss no one
isn't it funny that so much of you know
when you speak to people that have
achieved great things
it all seems to have been sparked by
like an earlier catalyst of
being bullied or feeling insecure and or
inadequate
in some way i see the same in myself the
reason why i am successful
without a shadow of a doubt is because
the feeling of
being broke and being inadequate in the
area that i lived in
and having all the windows on my house
smashed for a decade and
the grass being six foot high and but
living in all of these around all of
these white people zero black people at
my school other than my brother
and my other brother that feeling of
inadequacy
put pressure on me for like 15 16 years
and so my obsession as i wrote in my
diary 18
was i'm gonna have uh a million pounds
before i'm 25. i'm gonna have
a range river is going to be my first
car right couldn't even drive yeah it's
so funny i did the same
right i swear and it's so funny you say
it was the only black man in your school
because i was the only foreign guy on
mine
i was trying to contend with this whole
idea of having curly hair i was like i i
started relaxing it when i was 12 so
it'd be straight
and it and and i look back and i think
if i hadn't have gone through that in
the way that i had you wouldn't be where
you were not a [ __ ] shadow of a doubt
and and it's like that pressure releases
at some point
in different ways i could have ended up
in prison right my my friend said my
best friend said to me at 18 he said
steve and i remember where i stood when
he said he said you're either going to
be
a millionaire or you're going to be in
prison and i hit me like a ton of bricks
because he was telling the truth
i cared so much about escaping from that
pressure
and from that life that it was going to
channel itself into something so tell me
about your diary what did you write your
day
oh god i remember so funny right
i remember i wrote down and i will never
ever forget
i wrote down i'm going to be someone one
day
i wrote i wrote that down and then i
remember you went
you have blackberries yeah all right
back in the day and i used the right of
my blackberry
and i just believed it
and anyway when i went to the gym and
kind of figured it out along the way
um i fell in love with someone
at the gym like i was going he's now my
ex-fiance by the way everyone
we're no longer together but he
is a very important person in this story
because when i met him i was at rock
bottom
but i was also trying to find my feet
and i was becoming more confident in
myself
and that confidence confidence did grow
and attract the person that i was
supposed to be with at the time right
because i do believe your your vibe and
energy attract the people that you have
around you right
and i remember he was driving me to work
one day because i was waitressing
and i looked at him and i said i don't
know why i started instagram at this
point
had like 50 000 followers i started
instagram
in all honesty i started it just to see
how i looked doing exercises
and hollywood recorded me and i was like
oh my god i'm gonna break my back i
don't know what i'm doing i need to fix
my form
but somehow people started loving it and
anyway
he was driving me to work and i go jack
i don't know why but i
feel like we're gonna achieve something
by helping women
and generally said to me he goes yeah
whatever man you get to work i'll come
pick you up
i was like no i feel it and i started
crying
crying streams of tears he's like what's
wrong with you i was like no i believe
it i don't know what it is this is
feeling i can't explain
never had that feeling before and
here we are today what do you think that
feeling was
belief where did that belief come from
me
i just believed in me so much that no
one not even
you know the person i was with could
sway me another way
and i do think a lot of that comes from
persevering in the gym and growing that
discipline
and growing evidence right yeah that you
could right yeah because when you're
when you start doing something
good for yourself training was good for
me right
you start to build these disciplines and
habits and consistencies
and they transfer in other aspects of
your life
it's like a domino effect so
i started becoming more disciplined at
university i didn't need
10 cans of red bull to stay awake i was
focused
um i would excel all the time
and it wasn't because i put in extra
hours it was because i was so hyper
focused
where i was with who i was i was present
and if it wasn't for the gym i wouldn't
be able to have done that
so your ex fiance yeah jack
do you think you would have met him had
you not
built the confidence within yourself or
started to build a confidence within
yourself that the gym had given you
do you think you would have been ready
quote-unquote to have that relationship
with him at that time
if you were the old chrissy no um
and if i did if i was with someone
at the time i wasn't so confident it
would have been the wrong person
because you attract the energy that you
have you attract what you believe in
yourself
if you're constantly negative about
yourself if you're constantly just
trying to
make yourself believe you're you're just
not worthy you're always going to
attract that
and don't get me wrong there was
like dates in between jack obviously
when i wasn't with him by the way i mean
no i mean like after the guy that
cheated on me i had like went through
i went for a phase i went through dayton
and it's always the wrong guy i was the
wrong guy
and then it was i realized it's because
i'm trying to find happiness in other
people
constantly trying to find happiness of
people and then when i started focusing
on myself
he came along
you know a lot of women when they're in
the situation where they're lacking
confidence or self-worth or they're
feeling like something is missing
will and this isn't just women this is
men as well yeah right
they'll think that the answer is a
romantic solution yeah right
is it no it's not um
i've been there i've done that and
obviously i'm speaking from personal
experience you could find someone that
really helps you you know you could
genuinely find someone who
inspires you motivates you pushes you
and that's
so remarkable and if you do find that
person don't let them go
you know but unfortunately if you have
so much
self-hatred you are never going to be
satisfied in the relationship that you
are in because
you constantly have to find that person
to give you that happiness
you're constantly waiting for that
person to do something for you stable
right
it's unstable it is a lot of dependency
and um i think that the most rel most
important relationship you're ever going
to have is going to be with yourself
because when you go to bed at night and
you're in your own little thoughts up
here
right that's you and you that's you and
you
so you've got to fix that up here first
before you go trying to find a
a person to share your life with you
know
and you know so you end up you know
jack ends up proposing yeah you you
build a business together which is a
topic in and of itself which you're
you're still
working together with him on now yeah
and then at some point you both decide
in a very you know i've listened to your
story so you decide in a very
amicable mature way that this situation
isn't making both of you right
happy yeah and there was a sentence you
said where you said um
you and jack grew apart which i found
quite curious and i find it curious
because on this podcast we've we've been
talking a lot about monogamy
for whatever reason and this idea in
fact the last guest we had on dr arya
who was you know who people have been
really really blown away about um
he he was cheated on by his partners you
know and he found out in a really
horrific way that she was pregnant with
another man
yeah i listened to that okay and so on
that sentence about
growing apart this makes me ask you the
same question about monogamy if it's
possible for you to meet someone and
grow apart you know especially you know
because everybody's growing in some way
um what are your thoughts on monogamy
having been almost
to the altar with someone what are your
thoughts on monogamy and
i can i be honest i mean
please you never have to ask permission
again to be honest
i've never said this ever and i'm a
little bit nervous to say this
but i when i was with jack
i thought that that was my person
and i genuinely felt it in my heart and
my soul i never questioned it once right
and we grew apart and that's because
a lot of people don't know what was
going on behind the scenes last year
when i launched toner sculpt with jack
we had a lawsuit against
us you know no one really knew about
that
you know 50 grand in lawsuits trying to
get our app that we
we built just to be ours and then build
it from the ground up that's why we had
to
refurbish and relaunch the programs
because everything is now built
home grown in our offices with our
technology right
and do you know how much pressure that
adds to a relationship
i can't imagine and you're going home
and you're like what do you mean you
don't do this
what do you mean you didn't do that
hating each other resenting each other
because you think they're to blame
he thinks you're to blame i think he's
to blame
right and it's going to take a
very very special person
to fit into the shoes that jack left
you know he is such an incredible man
in every aspect works hard is caring is
loving as ambitious
is everything a woman would want in a
man unfortunately we grew apart
and it is unfortunate because i
genuinely
loved him and still do love him
unconditionally i'd give him my kidney
if he needed it and
it would take someone very very special
and confident to fill that space
up and i'm not gonna hold my breath
does that make sense i'm not gonna hold
my breath i'm gonna
you know let's just see where it goes
you think it's possible
um i think it's possible i think
anything's possible
i just think that it's gonna take
someone with a hell of a lot of
confidence and someone
that understands that i don't need
anything else but effort
and time from them i don't need your
money i don't need your gifts
i don't need so you're saying
you think that jack's shoes will be
difficult to fill and it's almost like
you're setting his shoes
as the standard of what you're looking
for in the future so it kind of begs the
question
well you've got two feet that fit those
shoes perfectly jacks
so why isn't he filling those shoes
i think if anyone turns around and says
to you that i
work with my partner and we run a
company of 30 people and hundreds and
thousands
of subscribers and you know an
ever growing company and we're so in
love
i i really literally will look at them
and be like how did you make that happen
working and being romantically involved
with someone is difficult
because let me tell you something when
you come home from work
you're coming home from work with the
same person what do you think you're
going to speak about when you get home
work what do you think you're going to
speak about
um after you have sex
work the work i'm being honest like
you you live and you breathe your
company jack is an entrepreneur and
himself
jack is a co-founder jack built this
with me
right yeah so if i'm going through all
those things as an entrepreneur as a
co-founder
he is as well i don't know if you're
answering the question chris
but i am answering the question it
doesn't work it doesn't work because you
work together yes
it doesn't work together it would have
probably worked
isn't that a shame when i when i um
when i first met jack i have never felt
that way about someone before
and i never once questioned our
relationship or i never once questioned
whether i didn't want to be with this
person
and it's funny because when we hire new
people at tone and scope they obviously
know
mine and jack's relationship and a lot
of employees tend to get a bit nervous
they're like are the co-founders going
to be better are they going to be nasty
to one another
and you know what they always say it's
insane how much respect and love they
have for one another it's actually a bit
worrying
how much respect and love we have for
one another and
had we not had tona sculpt we would have
100 be married by now
probably expecting a first child is jack
in a relationship
i don't know we don't speak about stuff
like that
i don't know if he's in a relationship
okay so here's another thing
jack's made it pretty clear he's been
like i don't know who i'm gonna find
that's
like you and you said the same to me
today and i've said the same thing about
him
um and another thing is i've been
with him for five years right i was with
him for five years i still work with
him in a normal situation you break up
and you
go separate ways go separate ways you
don't speak you don't see unless you're
stalking each other
which i would because i'm a weirdo so
i'd stalk you for a bit until i got
over you but what i'm saying is i see
him every day
so it's like how can i ever forget about
you you're always there
i speak to you every day i'm on the
phone to you every day we make executive
decisions together
every day i still go to you for advice
every day but why is i don't look at you
and want to kiss you
right do you no i don't i don't
i don't not not right now anyway but i
don't
to be in a relationship you have to have
that flair come on you have to have that
spark that
you you make me feel some type of way
and i know over time it will pass
and whatever but it sounds so weird but
i see him
almost like a best friend but then
everyone always tells you to marry your
best friend
so maybe have i got relationships all
wrong
right so i don't know
i don't know but all i'm saying is the
person that i'm with
and next with or whatever
they don't necessarily have like they're
not competing
because that's horrible you don't want
to compete kind of
somewhat unavoidable though especially
in chrissy's brain
but at the same time it's like jack
was is the most genuine person
like would always take care of me always
listen always put me first
would always want me to to succeed it
was every
check check check check check but why
are we not together
i don't i me myself i still don't have a
a fundamental reason as to why
you know i read the comments and people
were like
of course she would leave jack now she's
got like
millions of followers and has got money
of course she was she's gonna go
marry a rich arab man i was like
what you clearly don't know me you
clearly don't know me
but um i don't have a rich arab man as a
boyfriend by the way
i just want to clear that up but i don't
know if jack's dating i i don't know
what he's doing all i all i do know
is that i want him to be so happy could
you imagine life without him
oh no well that question just took my
breath away a bit
no i couldn't no i turned around
tomorrow said he said i'm leaving the
business i'm moving
no i'd be absolutely heartbroken
i'd be i'd be absolutely grieving
i couldn't imagine life without jack but
then again
don't they say the most
important person in your life as a
business owner is your
business partner you almost speak
special bond you always speak to them
more than you speak to the partner
you go to bed with but it's also and the
reason i asked that question
is i remember asking myself that
question about my business partner many
years ago
and i'm embarrassed and i thought to
myself what if they died
and it was like well then there's no
point me doing this business anymore
which is a really weird thought i had i
thought well then they were such a
fundamental part of the purpose and the
journey
and i it made me question you know why
i'm actually doing this and
i think with jack i think it's probably
true that um
a huge part reason why you do this
business is because of him you've been
through so much
together yeah i couldn't imagine doing
it with someone else
yeah but i also can't imagine doing it
without him and you've been through hell
and back together with
jack right yeah and that strengthens the
relationship like
you know so much been through so much
with jack
um you do five years with someone shit's
gonna happen shit's gonna hit the fan
is it is it a possibility to be back
with him
um like i've always said you can never
say never
and anything is possible however
if jack was to find someone right
and say oh like chrissy you know out of
respect he would have to sit me down
because we work together and be like i'm
with someone now
and if i see that that girl is treating
him so well
and looking after him in all honesty
that's all i hope
would you be a little bit jealous
probably
i mean i'm not gonna lie probably would
but and would you then question
the decision oh no i'm not the type of
person that if if
if i if i don't have you no one else can
on you know me and that's just weird
i mean you'd go home that day and start
thinking oh i would go home and be like
oh like damn you'd set reminders off
like alarm bells will start going off i
absolutely don't regret ending it
i've learned more about myself in the
year and a half of parting ways with
jack than i did in five years of being
with him
facts i don't regret ending it would i
feel some type of way if he were
he was with someone else you'd be
absolutely lying to yourself if you said
no
come on mate like we buddy was about to
get married
we own a company together of course
you'd feel some type of way but would i
be jealous no would i be happy if he was
happy hell yeah i would because
his happiness makes me happy is
in the future a possibility of me being
with him again i don't i don't know
how can i how can you possibly answer
that question when
the possibility of me parting ways with
him five years ago was
not even a vision i can't answer that
question
but if he was to find someone and be
truly happy and in love
and she was a good egg i'd be happy and
it's possible to be happy for someone
but also for it to suck at the same time
100 but that's only because you just
feel some type of way but deep down you
just want them to be happy
i think he will find someone i think
he's going to find someone who's really
genuine
are you smiling i wasn't smiling you're
smiling no i wasn't smiling i think you
are
i think you were smiling i think you
felt some type of way by saying that
no i really do i swear i
but yeah i've been honest enough now
till now to like lie
but but if when he does right
when he does which he will i just want
one thing from that girl
if you're listening out there to jack's
future wife i just don't want her to
sway
he's a mind on our business
does that make sense yeah oh leave tone
and sculpt you don't need it anymore
that's horrible like don't interfere
don't need to get involved love all
right
look at you but it's true
like i'm sorry but when i'm with a guy
if he starts telling me what to do with
my company
or if he starts telling me or it's me or
jack i'd be like
yeah get a grip it's jack
if you give me an ultimatum i don't want
to be with you
you know what this thing so i was i was
thinking about this earlier
and i've got some friends i wouldn't
call them necessarily friends but people
that i know personally
and they would hate because they're so
insecure as men
they would hate the idea of dating
someone as
self-made and successful as you mm-hmm
and it's a certain type of insecure man
i'm laughing because i already know
already been there
really yeah certain type of insecure man
that really is seeking to control
that would would not like a chrissy
because
you can't be controlled you can't be
controlled through gifts through
x and you've been there yeah i've been
there i've
done that like you know i remember one
time
go for it sarah was like yeah
sarah was my pa she's like yeah open up
but i remember one time when i was
speaking to this guy
you know after jack and i was going to a
lathe this was one of the biggest photo
shoots
for tone and scott this was you know to
refurbish the entire app and everything
like
brand new look brand new everything so
much money went into this i think
nearly 90 grand in production that's a
lot of money
[ __ ] to the money [ __ ] ton of money
yeah i mean i can put down two mortgages
for that yeah so as you can see like
what but when we do things we do things
right i
tone and sculpt and that's facts um
so i remember he sat down he was like
i don't know i just feel a bit you going
i said what do you mean what do you
think i'm gonna do
go and go and you know
go crazy with other men in la i'm going
to work
oh i don't know i don't know really
insecure
and i found myself thinking it was me
i was like wait a minute and then i sat
back and i was like no that's you
you're insecure that's a problem that's
not my problem
when la had the best time ever with my
team we had the most incredible time
you know met the most incredible people
came back most incredible campaign
and i felt good but had i let that
man sway me
maybe i i may have been a bit vulnerable
at the time and let's say he did sway me
what if i changed my eye and didn't go
that could have happened
was he intimidated by you and your
success do you think at the beginning
yeah 100
let's be honest i'm 20 oh my god i'm 26.
i'm 26. i was still 24. i'm
26 years old and you are killing the
game i'll say it because i know you're
too humble
no i no no no no no no
no i said it it's fine you didn't you
say whatever you want but it's not even
that it's
you know when you're 26 years old and
maybe you have a few things
um people start to obviously
feel a bit like you know i think it was
people start to feel like they should
have them i say something
when you talk about your success i get
awkward don't i i'm super awkward and
i'll can i just say an observation and i
think this is
a society problem not you problem men
aren't like that
no they're not i love coming up on here
and saying how much money they're making
and how much they're killing it how many
x wins that they've achieved um you
don't seem to be as comfortable talking
about your success and i feel like
that's a reflection of the society we
live in
uh honestly it's not even that it's me
i'm
very awkward with stuff like that like
can i be honest i don't even check my
bank accounts
i let my account and deal with it i i
i don't i i think for me i stay so
tunnel vision and the vision
so i wake up in the morning the first
thing i do is check
my mentions and dms and go on my
community pages
in that forum that's literally the first
thing i do
and if i start thinking about how am i
going to make a billion how am i going
to do this i'm going to do that
i don't know it becomes a bit
suffocating to the vision that you have
um and i was really number driven at the
beginning not
financially but on instagram followers
and
followers the more followers it means
i'm amazing the more likes it means i'm
fit enough to be here
you know and i got so obsessed i used to
almost like not think i was good enough
unless i got a certain amount of likes
or followers and i
completely lost sight of why i'm doing
what i'm doing
you know now i don't even check the
likes i get i don't even check the the
my statistics my team do
i don't check it because i don't care
what i care about is that comment that a
lady saying to me
oh my god this has helped me so much
this has made me so confident
that feeds my energy if i start thinking
how am i going to get 100 million how am
i going to juice
that will come i'm confident it will
come
but it's not my fundamental
you know and it's going to be focusing
on something else yeah i'm focused on
something else and
it's not that society has made me feel
uncomfortable to talk about my success
it's that i've you can speak to any of
my team like i
just don't care about it can i be honest
with you like
i am not thriving to
i don't know i'm not i'm not thriving to
have
the biggest house or the fanciest car
i mean i even said to you like i don't
have a fancy car a fancy house by the
way
and you were like i don't care yeah you
know like i don't really care about
stuff like
that i never i never have been like that
and it's not that i'm trying to be
humble it's like i literally don't give
a [ __ ]
i don't care about a fancy car never
have done
on the things that you do care about you
talked about these comments and these
dms you get um
i imagine you know because i get a
couple dms as well
you get a lot not a couple you get a lot
and uh
how how does it feel to have that sort
of responsibility when someone messages
you something so
deeply personal and that they're seeking
advice or guidance or they're just
sharing a problem with you how does that
feel in terms of
well how does it make you feel um
when can i message sometimes because you
know what to say
because i'm not qualified to deal with
certain situations
but at the same time the contradiction
with me is like you're giving that
advice
something yeah and i just want to
acknowledge the person but i know i
can't so and it would be almost
irresponsible for me to try and solve
their problem
100 you're not there to fix someone's
problems yeah but but
i think the value that i can bring is
just by like listening and acknowledging
but you know there's a spectrum right so
you have on one end i love what you do
in the other end you have
people that are suicidal or that are you
know
and um it's it sometimes it's a lot i
had this one video go viral 30 million
views and it was about depression
and i got 8 000 dm's that week from
people on that spectrum
and i just didn't know what to do i was
like
because when you read them some people
are really really suffering
and they've come to me because clearly
in some cases one girl that said she'd
barricaded herself in a room in egypt
and she was on the verge of suicide like
she didn't feel like she could speak to
anyone else and sometimes a stranger
yeah is the the most safe place to you
know
how does it feel that that has kind of
made me emotional no it didn't i did
the funny thing to that i remembered
that instantly this girl
barricaded in a room in egypt who would
watch this video
and had reached out to me to for me to
give her the answer she's looking for in
her life
which i'm not qualified to give right
all i can do is
be a friend in that in that situation um
but but i'm sure you get messages that
are
you know yeah i get um messages
every day thousands and um
so there's two things that i've started
to do one of the biggest teams we have
at tone and sculpt is the customer
support team right
and by the way this isn't because we get
influxes of emails
it's because we have a person for each
social
facebook community manager instagram all
of this stuff
and the reason being is we don't need
them
it's because i want every single person
to be heard and what you just said that
is exactly what i think as well you want
to be a friend
i call my community familia
i always use that word i always say
you're my sisters you're my familia
because at the end of the day i'm not
here to fix your problems but i'm here
to listen to your problems
i'm here to be the friend that you may
think you don't have in in your reality
you can't fix someone's problems you
can't offer
you know mental health advice because if
you say something wrong
god forbid anything happened but you can
listen
you can make feel make someone feel like
they're part of something
and that's the best thing i can do you
know yeah and you know i was i was
thinking then as well about the previous
topic we had i rarely switched back
but before you came here today there was
a question i actually wanted to ask you
about because
i only ask questions because i am
curious myself
sure and i'm trying to i think the
reason i ask these questions is i'm
trying to find similarities in some way
between a you know a person on your
journey and a personal mind the question
is
are you hard to date
today was one of those days in my life
where i'm filming this podcast with
chrissy i've got a ton of things going
on i've got tons and tons of emails
i'm sprinting around and like usual in
my crazy crazy world i am neglecting my
nutrition something that i
i have done for probably the last decade
and this is why
huel sponsored this podcast and why i've
been a huge customer for about three
years and why
when i was looking for a partner to work
with on this podcast hill was the
company that came to mind
it's a company that helped me with my
nutrition and for me to stay sort of
nutritionally complete
as is huel itself despite the fact that
i have a crazy
crazy unfi predictable unforgiving
schedule
and um i love it and it's it's such a
pleasure to get to have a podcast and to
have a partner
in huel and then julian who is the
founder and ceo
where i can talk about it and the
benefits it gives to me in such an
authentic way
if you've not tried huel and you are
someone that frequently
neglects your diet whether it's through
busyness whether you forget to have
meals because
of whatever's going on in your life i
implore you just to try it
just to check it out um they and heal
comes in many different like shapes and
sizes there's the powder
they've got like the savory meals now
and they have the bottles
and for me i've always loved the bottles
um so it's yeah it's a pleasure that
you'll sponsor this podcast and support
us in this mission
and they're the reason that we're going
to be scaling this podcast up
big time i was just chatting to um
chatting to some of the production crew
that worked with me and jack and dom
and i was saying that um now we have a
partner on the podcast
we can really take this up a level
you've seen me taken up one level this
season already
we're gonna take it up even further and
that's in terms of production in terms
of the guests in terms of
what we can invest into this into this
um piece of
content so thank you to huel check it
out try the chocolate flavor let me know
what you think if you are a hula gun
right and um i appreciate you listening
back to the podcast
the question is are you hard to date
um oh [ __ ] yeah i think so
i think i am i'm not gonna lie
like okay so here's the thing right i'm
super loving
when i'm with you i'll do anything for
you
like i'll look after you i'll make you
feel special
it's gonna be like but if you like it
but
no no like honestly like even i
i can honestly say like even sarah and
my pa will tell you like
i fall hard in love yeah
i head over heels for someone i'll fall
so hard for you um but i also fall so
hard out of love for you
oh [ __ ] that's the issue of me and
that's
facts and i hate that about myself
so much it's the one thing i hate the
most about myself
i'm a switch you do something to annoy
me
or you do something to kind of like
it's bad it's not healthy like i
people think i'm superwoman i've got my
own problems this like
i want my own issues i feel so in love
with someone and then if i don't see
that same level of love back
i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] self-defense
yeah i do think in relationships i'm
really i'm really defensive
and you know what i can't believe i'm
admitting all this but
yeah i i would say i am and i think that
um what are you defending yourself from
i don't know okay why are you are you
hard to date
yeah okay so so are you defensive
christy this is all about your diary
well come to me
no i want to know what you're defending
yourself from
because you you literally said if i
didn't get the same type of love back
okay okay so you're obviously very
motivated you're very inspired you're
very like
driven right thanks you're welcome i'm
the same like i just want to keep going
i want to grind i want to grind
so if i see someone kind of just not
doing the same
infuriates me like i'm almost like how
can you not have
passion for something how can you not
have a try for something
and then it leads me to believe that
hold on a minute if i did have the same
person that had the same level of drive
would we be compatible
maybe i do need someone a little bit
more like low-key
because then it will make me feel a bit
calmer when i'm home
it's all over the gap i don't know what
i want women don't know what they want
stop asking women what we want we don't
know what we want
we don't know what we want but what i
can say is
i think sometimes when we overthink
things especially me i overthink
relationships
all the freaking time i think sometimes
it's a good idea to just
take a step back and just relax a bit
because if someone is genuinely there
for you
willing to listen willing to take care
of you
and willing to always always put effort
in
stop being a [ __ ] pretty much you know
i i
me personally i'm i'm difficult to stay
i'm not gonna lie
i'm not gonna lie i don't even feel bad
saying that i felt quite free saying
that like i'm i'm difficult today
so no one said you should feel bad no i
i am and i
i feel bad for the guy but so i really
want to dig into that because i can
really really relate and that's why i
started laughing because
i've gone over the same predicament in
my head thinking maybe i need someone
that's super ambitious and has loads of
passions and there's a flagship person
and then i thought but then maybe they'd
drive me crazy because you know and then
so i flip-flop and usually when i'm with
one i think i want the other
same and then yeah and then when with
that i'm like nope
yeah that's literally me yeah i'll
like maybe we can figure this out today
i honestly can't and i think you know
what it is
i think it's because we are people that
are constantly switched on yeah like
neurotic obsessive
obsessive like with work with this with
that i'm not obsessive in a relationship
like if someone tries to tell me what to
do with my life i'd be like
no way and i couldn't imagine ever
trying to tell someone what to do with
their life
like if you want to do whatever you do
whatever you want to do that's your life
you live it the way you want to live it
um so
because i'm obsessive with my life and
my career
i'm constantly switched on so
if someone around me isn't i almost feel
like
i don't know she doesn't think they're a
bum
oh my god i think that's true
it's true yes i know it's so
true and then do you find yourself
feeling a bit lazy
yeah but also i i'm like steve don't
tell him because you're
passing your own world view and your own
values onto someone else
who doesn't want it yeah and you
shouldn't be trying to change people out
here
you accept them oh my god that is me i'm
literally like
what do you mean you don't want to be
ambitious in life what do you mean you
don't have a passion
what do you mean and i go crazy in my
head and this is happening in my head
whilst i'm looking at the meat
do you know what i mean like let's say
i'm like
let's say we're we're at dinner i'm
having a full-on-blown conversation in
my head like what do you mean i'm not
ambitious
what do you mean you don't want this and
he's just chilling you know you're not
doing anything wrong
and then i have to let you take a
breather and be like what am i doing i
can't
i can't push that on to someone i can
only push that onto myself i need to
chill out
connected to this maybe maybe not your
parents
hard working oh my god so hard working
um came from another country came from
another country
um immigrated at the back of the lorry
you know i immigrated back of banana
lorry
yeah and um i remember we landed in
france
and my family got arrested because we
were immigrants and they separated us so
they put
me my my brother in one room my dad in
another room he could see him through
the glass
and i remember crying and crying and
crying like dad dad dad i didn't know
what's going on i was four years old
but i still remember that i'll never
forget the the prison room was turquoise
i'll never forget that and when we came
to this country
my mom and dad worked hard
my mom worked three jobs my dad worked
as a hb1 lorry driver every single night
you know every penny they had they saved
they saved they saved um
my dad had a pretty bad gambling problem
i'm gonna be honest my mum was
constantly trying to like
fix that problem and
i've never actually mentioned that ever
before
ever and as much as i love my dad with
my entire heart and and i
want nothing more for him to be happy it
caused a lot of strain on my mum
like trying to feed her family trying to
like work hard trying to save trying to
take us on holiday you know
um so to save money and then to have the
person you love gambling away it's like
what's the point like i don't understand
why i'm with this person but in my
culture you don't leave the man you're
with
you're stuck with them but my mum even
though he was like that my mum
loved and loves my dad so much it's
pretty bizarre
because that would be enough to take
anyone off but she just believed in him
he doesn't do any more
believed in him and nourished him and
loved him so much
and together they grew better um
so for me if i have a man and he like
places a bet on something
it triggers me to think he's going to be
gambling and i'm like oh my god no
sorry out he's put one bet down and i
think he's
canvased you know what i mean it's crazy
so
i asked that question for a reason gone
um
because we've we've established that we
have very much
similar traits and relationships that we
we tend to really value
hard work and ambition and it tends to
be the case
that the value we attribute to hard work
and ambition probably comes from
a childhood where um
hard work and ambition were the thing
that might have got us out of some
[ __ ] let me
tell you from my example all right so
very much the same as yours
but switch the parents so i came from
africa i was born in africa came to the
uk
my dad had like a pretty good job but my
mom you could all call it a gambling
addiction
she had this she has both gambling
addiction on one hand because she played
there was probably a thousand lottery
tickets if i opened any drawer in our
house
okay but on the other hand she she was
she was
she couldn't stop starting businesses to
the point that
the reason why we were so poor we never
had birthdays or christmases or went on
holiday at all ever period
was because my mom spent all the money
trying to become a millionaire
by starting these businesses they'd all
fail within six months because she can't
read or write
and my dad was the unconditionally
loving calm
supportive won't leave you even though
you're an absolute [ __ ] parent right
so there's one yeah so in my house i
think when i think about why i am the
way i am now
i think money was such a big problem
that in our house it was the cause of so
much pain mm-hmm same that i grew up
valuing it so much and the thing that
would get you it which
would to me would be like you know my
what i thought was happiness
was like hard work ambition like my
parents worked so hard that they
wouldn't even be that in the house when
i went to bed or when i woke up
and so i value hard work and ambition
because my parents taught me it because
it was the cure to our problems
right so and especially as immigrants
right there's a different there's like
an
immigrant vibe i get you yeah i get you
don't we don't even have to talk about i
just get you
so like this is part of the reason why i
think in relationships when someone
doesn't have those values when they
don't value hard work and ambition i'm
like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah
there's probably something wrong with me
i don't think there's anything wrong
with you i think i
i'm i'm not going to sit here and think
there's something wrong with me not
wrong
it's like it's the result of my traum my
traumatic childhood experience maybe i
wouldn't change it for the world
do you know what it is i swear to god i
think it's it's the fact
that okay
so a lot of people
when we moved to england i was never
allowed to like go
to stay over other friends houses my dad
is super strict like i couldn't even
wear skirts around him
absolutely not forbidden and so when i
did used to go to my other friends
houses like english culture
it was a completely different vibe like
their family was different like their
moms and dads were different
and then when i'd come to my house it
was different and i
didn't understand it so my dad has
always wanted me to marry an albanian
man it's like his dream he's like please
marry an albanian man
you two will be amazing together like
this and i'm like
dad i don't care what he is so long as
i'm in love
and it happens to be that the guys i've
been with have been
english and the cultures are completely
different and it it i don't understand
like sometimes when they do things i
don't understand
examples like okay
so in my household mediterranean loud
proud like
very like good really yeah super loud i
am super loud i love it
but you know you come to my house and my
mum will have dinner ready for you
my mom will buy you slippers to make you
feel like home you know and she'll
she'll welcome you hug you kiss you on
each cheek
but then when i'd go to jack's families
for example as much as they were so
loving so caring it just wasn't the same
like you'd have dinner different times
or
and i didn't understand it because i've
been brought up in a family where
everything's together like togetherness
and everyone's got each other's backs
and everyone's solid so
to have a different culture thrown into
the mix
sometimes it does clash and it does like
cultures are different
but that doesn't mean one culture is
better it just means it's different
so it's up to you whether you want to
learn both cultures and
and meet in the middle it would be
easier if i went for an albanian guy
because their cult
culture is the same and i've been
brought up in that culture
but obviously jack's culture is
completely different so
i've had to kind of like
you know find the middle find that
that middle ground i guess i don't know
what you call it but find that balance
are you scared that you might not ever
meet the right person all the time i'm
all the time scared
i'm 26 years old and as women we're told
we have
a time frame if you're not 30 you have
kids you're
too old if you if you have kids at 40
what kind of mum are you
all this bloody [ __ ] around us all the
time see how much pressure that adds as
a woman
all the time so much pressure you got to
get married you got to have kids you got
to be a mom you got to be a mum
before 30. oh that's when i like
breathe out so much pressure and it
petrifies me
it honestly petrifies me because a lot
of people around me
in my industry are married or i'll have
children or have like
a fiance and i had that and i almost
think to myself i had that and i let
that go
and sometimes you you think do you know
and this is probably i'm asking this
question again for my own reasons so
you do you ever consider the fact that
you might be too busy
being entrepreneur no you're never too
busy for someone you love
i don't think that's the case i don't
think um
i'm too busy you think you're what
you're doing with with your businesses
and as an entrepreneur
might prevent you um being
uh aware and forming a healthy
relationship when the prospect arises
do you know what i think it is when you
have a nine to five
you clock out you come home you switch
off
you don't clock out you're working
constantly even if you're in this room
you're still at the back of your head
thinking about your business you're
thinking about something you need to do
something
to check off something you need to
approve something to expand on
so it's it's so guilty for me to say
this i feel bad saying it but i could be
in a room with you and i'm thinking
about my companies
constantly and someone who has a nine to
five doesn't
understand that because it's like you're
switched off at five
and sometimes i feel bad saying i do
kind of wish i can switch off at 5 p.m
but i just can't
and i think it's not necessarily i'm too
busy at some constantly thinking
even if i'm in the room with you i'm
constantly thinking about what i have to
do
you can make someone feel pretty lonely
just by being even if you're sat next to
them yeah
you're often you know yeah i often say i
say like when i'm with somebody
my aim isn't for them to ever understand
me it's just to understand
that they don't understand yeah because
i think i'm like too difficult to
understand if i'm quiet for an hour it
doesn't mean i don't love you it means
that i've just got an email
so true and it's just [ __ ] me and i
actually don't want to always share
things at home because you're offloading
yeah you're offloading and i don't want
to be back because i could offload 24
7. oh trust me so can i sarah's always
like oh
here we go again um but it's
true like you know your phone is buzzing
off constantly
you could get a dm by someone you could
you could get a message an
email and it's like oh [ __ ] really
and you're just sitting watching a movie
with your partner tell me about that
part of being an entrepreneur i think
that's why i really started the podcast
in the first place was
i want to hear about the [ __ ] of
running a business the unexpected
unpredictable
life-shifting [ __ ] that happens
yeah your life is you breathe and you
live your businesses
i think this is something people don't
understand you live
and you breathe your companies they are
your babies
no one and nothing can get in the way
and no one understands that they see the
money the success
the followers the this the that the
blingy cars whatever
the hell you want to see and
let me tell you the reality you don't
have much time
you suck at relationships
you don't have many friends and the
friends that you have you don't really
see them
um when you do have time to yourself
you never switch off ever
you are the biggest self-critic ever
you constantly think that you could be
doing better and that pressure
is insane mentally and physically it
drains you
and um another thing is that i really
just want to say
um if you think a life of an
entrepreneur
is so glamorous this is the first time
i've put on jeans
in i would say i'm blessed i feel
privileged
i don't know how long but i don't live
in jeans i live in sweats and sliders
so if it sucks so much it doesn't suck
and you know what i'm trying to say yeah
i know exactly what you're saying
but i'm also here to to try and help
people understand
multiple perspectives because people say
okay so you've criticized you know
you've talked not criticized but you've
talked
about the downsides right why'd you
still do it because you could
just say do you know what i killed it
hang up your
your gym yeah your active wear clothes
oh your shoes i don't know what people
would say
and you could say that's it i'm done why
don't you
oh no why not gosh the feeling i get
when i
when i see someone's transformation
nah that fills me up like
that fuels me when i see
a transformation when i see someone who
had um
a mental a mental health disorder or an
eating disorder and has is now thriving
do you know that is
so unexplainable that nothing else
matters
i'd rather not have a relationship to be
frank with you
i really am not that fast so long as i
can
continue to help as many women as
possible
for me that's enough and that's why i
don't stop
is there an endpoint in all this i hope
not
okay there's no like mountain top
there's no no
i i think that
you know you're you're told in life that
you need to go to school you need to go
to university you need to achieve this
right so then you achieve this and
you are not satisfied so you need to
achieve this
and then this and then this i don't have
goals for financial
status for awards for anything like that
i had
maybe two goals and i've achieved one of
them
which i won't share because it's
actually very top secret but you'll see
it next year okay
um but
if you have these um
tangible goals i'm thinking now what it
is i'm like you finally married an
albanian man i'm like what
oh yes daddy i did no no
i didn't i didn't no i'm not married
nope that's actually very depressing
thank you
um but no it's like you you
goals are like you you know when you
wrote in your diary i want a range rover
right you got a ranger or what then just
total anti-climax
yeah well i want a million dollar house
cool what then you're lonely in your
house
your house is so big you don't know what
to do with it by the way my house is not
so big i don't want to do it i need more
space
but you see what i'm saying so i don't
have those types of goals because
they're not attainable
is there a point in when you're building
the businesses you run where
you had your worst ever day because i
can think about the worst days that i've
had in business
what was the what was the one that
sprung to mind straight away
oh god um okay so when
i'm i'm a woman in tech right so
with an app there's complications that
you are not even prepared
for there's maybe a bug maybe this maybe
that so obviously when this lawsuit was
happening to get
my app back um from the developers from
the
old developers it was a third party
company
and when we transferred it to brand new
servers that are obviously
you know pretty much ours um
because servers are just so huge but um
i didn't know anything about tech when i
started now you speak to me tech i know
tech language
okay so it's actually i'm very proud
because for someone who literally didn't
understand what the hell the server was
i was like what's the first time you
heard about it there's a bug did you
think oh lady bird
i honestly don't like it's embarrassing
but when the transition happened the
whole app went
right shut down and imagine when you
know when instagram shuts down people
like oh my god instagram sucks like
fu instagram okay but
this is my company now so when it shuts
down
it's like i can't i can't i can't pay
for my employees
i can't pay for my office i can't do
this i can't do that
when it shut down my whole face shut
down with it i was like [ __ ]
what do i do now this is it we lost 10
000 subscribers in one day
okay you times 10 000 by 13.99
yeah it's a lot of [ __ ] money a lot
of money in one day gone
gone that was probably the one of the
worst days
and i just sat back and i looked at jack
and i just said to him
what the [ __ ] do we do now jack b and
jack he was like don't worry
we'll gain them back on don't worry why
are you stressing this is what happens
well would you be while we're stressing
idiot
what do you mean he's like chill out but
um
yeah that was probably the worst day and
i just remember i
i lost so much weight right i lost
i would say i was 56 kilograms i went
down to
49 in like 56
yeah i went down to 49. seven kilograms
yeah but i went down to 49 so can you
imagine in what space of time
um three weeks to four weeks
i couldn't keep anything on i wasn't
eating i wasn't sleeping i lost
everything then me and jack parted so
and i was still producing videos still
producing content still
how long was the up down for it was down
for three days
three days and i was still producing
content going on instagram don't worry
guys like we'll still get out there i
wasn't eating wasn't sleeping wasn't
doing anything i just
broken up the person i was going to
marry
i was in a house with my dog the house
that i built with the man i was supposed
to be with
i didn't know what the hell i was doing
anymore at that point i thought
i thought i should give up not gonna lie
but yeah
i was like this is it now no no i'm
giving up i've got my law degree i'm
gonna go back to doing that this is just
too much stress
and then i did and i just kept going
just kept going something inside me was
like you just have to keep going please
don't give up please don't give up
chrissy
you talked about um your own battles
with mental health
um over the years i think i think i read
that you
you said you'd suffered with depression
at various stages yeah early on can you
tell me about that
yeah huge like i mean
a lot of people see a very
picture-perfect image on instagram which
i'm to blame
just like everybody else you want to you
want to showcase the best bits of you
nothing wrong with that you keep doing
you if that works you keep doing you
but i have been in such
dark places that i couldn't
i couldn't picture wanting anyone
to feel what i felt in those places even
someone i
resent not that i resent anyone but i
wouldn't even want that for them
these dark places suck you in so much
that you honestly start to contemplate
whether you just want to stop feeling
that feeling
period like just be done with it
and i'll never forget i was laying in
bed
one day and i was so
depressed so depressed that i just
thought to myself
it'd be so much easier if i wasn't here
that's so much easier just
quit just leave
and i cried myself to sleep and i woke
up the next morning and it almost
felt like in my dream i'd made it happen
if you know what i'm trying to say
without saying it and i just thought
i need to stop because i cannot go on
like this
and i think when i try and explain to
people i've i know those dark places
i've been in those dark places they
don't believe me because they see me for
the person i am today
they don't see the person that fought so
hard to be
where i am today mentally not even about
the success the business is mentally
that's the most important thing up here
this is the most important thing you can
have all the money in the world
all the businesses in the world you can
have 300 employees multiple companies
who gives a [ __ ] about that if you up
here are so
not okay so yeah i've been through dark
places but
i've also picked myself up multiple
times and i've had to brush my shoulders
off and get [ __ ] done
and that's why i keep saying to every
single person out there you have to do
this for you do this for
you this is the the biggest and most
important thing i can say to you
and now that you have you know you've
built this empire this little fitness
empire which is
rapidly growing do you ever find
yourself in those dark places even today
yeah not as bad um
but i find myself um
i find myself wondering if
i'll ever have like a somewhat normal
life
so like what we discussed
will i ever find someone again
will i be in love will i get married
will i have children like i want
children i want to be married i believe
in those things i want those things
but sometimes i wonder if those things
are going to happen
for me and i do wonder i just maybe need
to stop overcomplicating things in my
mind
but i can't switch off and maybe the
only way i know to switch off is just to
quit
you see what i'm saying it's a vicious
circle but if i quit i'll be so
angry at myself for quitting it's like
ongoing it's constant it doesn't stop
so um and do you think part of
that fear comes from the fact that you
believe the way you are now
and how you live and work now and how
obsessive you are now
is probably not like conducive or um
it's probably not going to allow that
other all those other things you want
to yeah to come true right so like you
think well something's going to have to
give at some point is that
i do i'm not going to i i literally
think like that i'm not gonna lie like
so when when toner scope
was built um we i didn't i honestly
didn't realize it would grow the speed
it did with little to absolutely no
marketing expenditure
so everything's been hyper organic in
the space of
12 months we now have a team of 22
people when it was just me and jack
12 months ago 22 people an office in
in in london we know what the rent is
like in london it's
off the chain um 120 growth
you know month by month it's rapid
growth
we've just launched a brand new trainer
um
who is like insane
and um i keep saying to myself okay when
i get to this point i can
relax and i say that to sarah all the
time
i keep saying i keep mentioning sarah
but but because she is the one person
that
knows me probably better than my own
blood
because she's with me everywhere i go
and she is the person i speak to about a
lot of things
so i always say to okay when i get to
this point with tone and scope
i can breathe and bless her she's like
yeah yeah
she knows in her head i want more and i
want more
but it's not i want more it's that i
believe we can do more and i believe we
can do more
and strive for more so when does it end
when does it end it doesn't end that's
what i'm trying to say so you have to
make peace with it
you have to make peace with the fact
that it's not supposed to end
but you also have to make peace with the
fact that you need to make maybe some
self
self self-adjustments and and be a bit
critical with yourself
because if you're going in a
relationship and constantly thinking
that that person should be on your level
that's that's my problem i need to deal
with that's not their problem
you know it's not fair on them how'd you
deal with that
i think it i think it takes time
i think you're not sure are you
no i'm not sure about your body language
oh god i figured that one out it's okay
to not have it figured out right i don't
have it figured out and i'm someone who
doesn't like not having things figured
out
right yeah yeah i get that um but i do
think i need to stop being so mean
it's this balance right between trying
to figure it out now because you kind of
want to be able to have a plan and have
you know
but then also realizing that you
shouldn't overthink this thing
and that you should maybe just you've
literally made me feel in this podcast
like i'm the most impossible person to
be with
i'm not i'm just asking the questions oh
no no i
can't lie i'm not going to lie just to
make myself sound good no
it's it's a very important part of being
a successful person that it has this
crazy neurotic obsessive brain
yeah i do ambitious and that's but also
has these other things they want and
life is a drop at you you can't have
everything at the same time so what
we're talking about now is like
compromising how you reach that
compromise in your life if possible
i'm in the same place i have no idea how
that's gonna happen but do you do you
want kids
i do want kids do you want to get
married um i'm not so concerned about
the concept of marriage but i want to
have a long-term partner because i want
to have kids
and so i'm willing to commit long-term
if it's a marriage if it's
signing some other piece of paper if
there's no paper i like don't really
care too much about the whole marriage
thing if it matters so much to the
partner
i'll do it but i don't i was saying on
the last podcast no i see what you mean
i don't have a great case for why the
law or or a religion should be involved
in
love i don't think it has a great track
record with love yeah so i'm like i
think that's an idea which we all as a
society need to just
reconsider yeah what you mean like i'm
gonna my closing statement on this point
is
we are all so different you are
different from me only a little bit
but then like you're different from your
assistant and i'm different from mine
and
my friends from school so logically you
would think the answer to how we form
our romantic connections
would also be unique and different like
and i think at any time in life where
the script tells you everyone has to go
through this door
when you are a different shape it's like
putting a triangle in a square
like of course i think that's when you
have to question things so i got kicked
out of school because i just stopped
going
dropped out of university after one
lecture and i've tried to navigate my
life my way through life just rejecting
the things that i meant to just accept
blindly
and marriage is one of them where i'm
like can i achieve all the things i want
to in a relationship without that
paper yeah and i put on my linkedin last
week i said um i basically said to the
world i think marriage is
a concept we need to reconsider for
everyone someone proved me wrong
and one guy commented he said i've been
in a marriage for 45 years
we love each other we've done this i
said could you have done that without
the marriage
yes okay then yeah so but you would do
it if
she or i don't know he whatever maybe
but then i need to be honest here
because you know if they really wanted
to get married
i'd ask them why they really wanted to
get married i'm not gonna lie i am the
same
like for me a piece of paper doesn't
define my love for you
okay let's talk about this then so why
do you why do you want to get married
do you know what it is like this is me
being a woman
i just really want to dress we can do
the wedding
like that's marriage is different from a
wedding in a ceremony someone said that
on my post
yeah i guess yeah i mean look
my my dream wedding would genuinely be
like on the beach
having like burgers and beers with the
closest friends and families running in
the ocean i don't want it like a big
fancy
party i feel like you just described
your dream day yeah
literally if you could do that like this
week but if i said to you because you're
so busy if i said to you what's
what do you want to do right now i bet
anyone and you'd say you know what i'd
love to be on the sofa and just eat my
favorite food for the people i love
yeah of course right of course yeah over
going out getting smashed of course
that's what i'm saying but a lot of
people the only thing is my brain is
like go on your laptop and check your
emails
see that's what i mean because you're
upset because i love it you know what i
mean yeah but
what i'm saying is to other people they
want a big wedding a big
big fuss i hate fuss
i absolutely hate fuss over me and it's
so funny because like even my team
surprise premier surprise birthday party
i was so awkward i was like don't ever
do that again i
i hate all eyes on me yes although my
business is built on all eyes on me
do you see how that's so contradictory
it's the same i used to my previous
assistant um who ended up being my
girlfriend long [ __ ] story which
we're not going to go into
whoa
i don't actually know if sophie so my
current assistant sophie's been with me
for four years
i know she knows this but sophie do you
know this do i
do have i ever said to you when it's my
birthday or when it's like social change
anniversary to not make a fuss about it
and the reason why i say this is because
i get so much attention as it is
and so much fuss for like being the
founder being the ceo the eyes are
always on me
you just don't want it you're like no no
no no yeah the same right
i'm the same and i always just feel like
oh i don't know so that's why my dream
wedding
day if that day will come is to just
oh my god 20 30 people max
closest friends and families my my dog
there and just to have the person i love
and i always say i want to be in a room
full of people and look at the person i
love and just me and him
understand each other you know what i
mean that feeling where you look at them
and you're just like i get you
i get you and that's that's what i crave
that's what i want and you're right a
piece of
paper doesn't define that feeling only
you define that feeling in that person
so i don't need a piece of paper you're
right um i guess i just want the concept
are you scared of death who me no not at
all
hear me no i'm not
i'm i'm not are you no i'm not no
i'm not like um i'm scared of not living
yes i'm scared of like i really want to
do
things i want to explore i want to do
things i want
to you know my my dream vacation
would be to not have my phone there i
don't care about a selfie i don't care
about this i just want to be
present in the moment and if i if i told
you that you were going to die
a week from now what would you so much
what would you regret
so much tell me not living just working
there you go not living like
as much as i love doing what i l what i
do i'm not gonna lie
i i've built what i've built telling
people to look after themselves
and i forget to look after myself and
that's why when i do train and when i
exercise
it's the only time i do feel like i'm
doing something really special for
myself
and i've like i do a lot of skipping
right amazing at skipping by the way
thank you i watched you the other day i
was like oh my god did you like i
thought i was a good skipper no and i
saw you like dancing while skipping and
i was like oh she's [ __ ] of course
she's doing like a double crossover and
i just had to
i started to feel really inadequate and
insecure as a man it was fine so i just
had it it happens all the time
but you know why i skip why is that
uh you have to be [ __ ] present
because if you're not present you get
whipped
right and when i'm skipping
i literally feel like i can't think
about anything else but the rhythm
and for someone who's always on switched
on someone who's always doing things you
know people always tell me go
go meditate do yoga can i [ __ ]
yeah can i [ __ ] i'm like i let you go to
meditate and i'm thinking about
my my to-do list like but when i'm
skipping
i'm so engrossed in it yeah that
i'm literally so present in the moment
and it makes me feel alive
same thing with training i'm so
engrossed in training
and that's why so many women when i say
to them just train
you're a mom you got to think about your
children you're you're a student you've
got to think about your studies
you're trying to trying to make money
because you don't know when you're going
to pay
your rent just train it's the one moment
that you can ignore the entire world
and do something for yourself so
i really want to loot background to this
point
about if you were to die next week oh
you were trying to avoid it
yeah i was because you know the answer
yeah but i want to hear the answer
because i'm asking this
i would feel the same way right maybe
feel awkward my palms are sweating it
makes you feel a little bit
uncomfortable right
it does because i
love my job so much like i love what i
do
it it i thrive off it
but on the flip side i do wish i was
so i'll stop being such an annoying
little [ __ ] and just take some time off
for myself you know let's stop being so
annoying to yourself chrissy just take
some time off it's okay
it's okay to go do things you love doing
like traveling obviously right now it's
pandemic but you know what i'm trying to
say
like travel like maybe take a week off
and just
breathe um but i can't
i can't i don't know what's wrong with
me i just can't are you the same
i'm the same is there something
again i'm just exploring this is there
something strange about that where you
feel like you know
you're saying you're saying i can't it's
like you don't have a choice
but at the same time you're telling me
that if you were to die next week
you would regret not living
yeah oh my god this is such a
heavy-laded question um
i feel like i feel like this is the
therapy session i needed
but it's it's so true what you've just
said you've literally
just you've shut me up you've shut me up
because
i can't you're like like [ __ ]
[ __ ] shut her up but it's true like
i can't stop working because
something keeps telling me i can't stop
right now
not yet but on the flip side if i was to
die next week
i'd regret not taking some time off for
myself to do the things that i love
doing i love going to museums
no one knows that a lot i literally love
looking at things but you think that's a
waste of time i do
right now right now yeah and time is
every entrepreneur's biggest asset
time is everything how could it possibly
be a waste of time if it's the thing you
would regret
the the reason why i think this death
question is so revealing
is they they do all of these there's a
a lady called bonnie ware who was um she
worked with um i think it's called
palliative patients which are people
that are about to die
they've gone home to die and she asked
them the question
what are your biggest regrets and she
wrote it down and she was doing this for
years and she wrote a blog about it
and there's a certain sort of
retrospective clarity you'll get
in that moment when there is nothing
going forward for your life
about how you should have made your
decisions in that moment you can imagine
only the things that matter people what
that girl said about your hair
none of this [ __ ] won't [ __ ] matter
the playground [ __ ] none of it will
matter you'll just be left with the
things that truly mattered
and so putting yourself in that mindset
i call it like deathbed thinking
allows you to look at how you're living
your life now and see if it's in
accordance with the things that will
matter
in that like final moment and so
i asked this question because i think
the same about me i'm like if you told
me today
i had four days left to live i'd be like
why didn't i have a better relationship
with my family
yeah why didn't i go see my niece i
don't have a relationship with my
brother
well yeah you know i have a [ __ ]
relationship with my with my mom in
particular yeah
i don't see my niece and my two nieces
enough i've probably seen them i know
three or four times
she's maybe three years old she's only
two hours away and so i think these
things about myself and i think
okay so but what are you sacrificing
have you made a change
because no one's ever asked me that see
the question is now you've asked
yourself that
i think it'll always be there but but it
won't be
but no one's ever asked me that so now
you've got me thinking oh [ __ ] i need to
get sarah to put me holiday because
[ __ ] me i need to live my life but it's
like
in all honesty i'll probably leave today
and keep doing what i'm doing
day in day out until at some point
you'll learn this lesson the hard way
facts and
you know um recently one of the most
important people of my life passed away
the woman that gave me a home you know
um
you know you know you know my best my
best friend holly who is literally my
sister her mom gave me a home when i was
homeless
and you know she didn't once mentioned
the months she left let me live there
the food i ate the hot water i used not
once
ever brought it up and i saw her on her
dying bed right
and i held her hand and i just kept
thinking to myself
nothing matters at this point and you
know what holly said to me
she goes i would have called you sooner
but i was scared you were doing
something
and at that point i i it hit me like
i looked down i went never say that
again you call me when you need me
i'm always there for you but it's the
fact that we've
the people around us know how busy we
are that they sometimes feel like oh
maybe i just shouldn't
the most important people even my mom
doesn't know she goes i don't
call you babe it's okay i know how busy
you are and i say so no you call me when
you want me and you need me
and it's not that you've told people not
to call you right it's that they think
that
you're just so busy that it'll be a
disruption because you've made them feel
that way
yeah yeah i'm to blame 100
and you know you have to take a step
back and you have to realize what
matters in life
and that for me
that moment there i just realized to
myself and i messaged
every single person i loved the most and
i said i don't care how busy i am i'm
always here for you
always so that's a real personal moment
for your best friend and i'm
i imagine you said earlier that you
don't have many friends
um i have acquaintances but like
close friends you know like friends no i
don't think
i don't think a lot of people do that if
you really like ask
i don't have many friends yeah like i
have people
that are there like acquaintances and i
have people that i would genuinely die
for
those are my friends you know and i can
count them on my hand
polly is one of them other people have
more friends is that a fair statement
typically yeah sure but i don't really
care if you have more friends than me to
be honest i'm happy with the people i
have
because you have more friends with me
doesn't make you more superior or makes
you a better person because you have
more people
around you it's just you know i'm
only 26 i don't know how many friends
i'm going to have at 62.
so i have friends do you see what i'm
saying
probably less maybe yeah according to
the days
maybe but at the same time i couldn't
have asked for better friends that i
have now
and the friends i have now would protect
me and look after me and they know i
would do anything
for them that's what matters
not having a hundred friends i want one
good friend
not a hundred random friends so i i
asked that question because
i think i've definitely struggled to
make and to hold on to friendships
because of the way i've been over the
last decade
in the same way relation like normal
relationships i found that i don't
invest enough
in my friendships as much as i probably
should
okay i'm going to be completely honest
um
people come and go right
people come and go and it's so bizarre
because
i know it sounds crazy but i've pretty
much
built a virtual community right and i
feel like
that's my team even though i may have
not met
these women physically i feel like they
get me more than the people in my own
life
is that weird do you think that's weird
you think it's a bit weird don't you be
honest
i don't know if it's like i speak it's
unusual it's
a very curious thing you've just said
yeah like
you should i don't know if you've ever
seen or maybe not but when i go on a
live
workout and i work out with with with
hundreds of thousands of women
i don't see them they see me but i feel
the energy
i i can't explain it to you i i sound
crazy right now and people probably
think i'm an absolute
crazy psycho weirdo but let them think
what they want when i'm like
reading a dm right or when i'm going
live for a workout or when i add a new
workout on and when i repost people
because
you you see i repost a lot of people
right um
and half the time i don't even tag tony
sculpt i just repost the woman
with a sweaty selfie or whatever and
that to me i almost feel like that's
enough friends like i have friends for
life this is my family my unit my team
my tribe
and as crazy as i may sound
i feel like that tribe understands me
more than the people in my life so
that's when i go on social media and you
see
me understand that's me because i feel
like
we're friends and you get me and
it's crazy because they do get me and i
get them
they get my sense of humour they get me
trying to dance
on camera and be stupid i don't care i
sometimes forget i have 2.3 million
followers and i come
friends well i sometimes forget right
have you seen that i come online and i
don't have makeup on
i forget i genuinely forget and i'm like
oh [ __ ] my skin's a bit crusty right now
and i just posted that
to 2.3 million people what's my crazy
ass thinking
and i sit back and i'm like oh okay i
don't care but the nature of the
internet is that you would of course
you've got 2.3 million people
there's a lot of people in there that
are hurting themselves and that want to
make you feel like [ __ ] too
can i be honest i'm very lucky
really yeah i'm very lucky man i
don't get much negativity
i don't and when i do
um if like someone's been horrible
on a post because i have i have a big
insecurity about my boobs
all right like they're they're saggy
i'll say it
and cool i've always had a big
insecurity about it i remember this one
one girl just ripped them to shreds she
was just like ill
like they look disgusting and saggy i
didn't even see the comment
until i started seeing the community
members reply back to her
now there's a difference between
replying back to someone and being like
you need to stop that was hurtful
and then replying back meanly if you're
replying back me that's not nice like
you you don't cure hate with hate right
so if i see someone being really nasty
so i don't like that like i'd rather you
not defend me i don't want that
you don't know what that girl's going
through just because she's being mean to
me you don't know what she's going
through the pain she must be in
you don't know but when i see someone
like hey says like you need to chill
because that's not nice you don't know
what that comment could do to someone
that's a team
that's a community that's the family
right there
so i'm pretty blessed i don't get as
much negativity as maybe other people
i'm pretty pretty blessed touch word
that doesn't change
um but listen i
i don't know how to explain it to you
and i'm gonna sound hella crazy right
now but
the the community i have man it's
something special
like special it's something that
it's it's unexplainable the feeling they
give me
and that to me is my friends
as weird as i may sound and lonely as i
sound
so some of the things you're working on
right yeah so you've got a book coming
out
yes which is exciting tell me about this
so exciting so
i'm officially an author oh my god
um so my book do this for you how to be
a strong woman on the inside and out
is not your average fitness book so i'm
pretty sick and tired of
20 day challenges and kind of telling
women that
oh my god do this 20 day challenge and
you're going to lose 10 pounds
oh shut up it's draining jarring stop
i'm going to teach you how to create
habits discipline consistency longevity
that's what it's about you know all the
programs on the toner sculpt app
are some of them are year long
it kind of goes against the typical
sales sales script of something with
status quo like small effort from you
big results that's what sells right yeah
five days
you'll lose 100 pounds yeah you know but
that's very honest of you and i think
that's
real right yeah no you're not you're
gonna lose weight of course
of course you're gonna lose weight if
you're doing stupid amounts of cardio
cutting out specific food groups and
you're literally depriving yourself
of course you're gonna lose weight not
sustainable is it sustainable no
so the way i always say is funny enough
in a relationship
if you're constantly just like horrible
to someone all the time
is that sustainable not really you have
to nourish you have to love you have to
care you have to
show effort consistency that's what
works same thing with
training it's the constant effort you
put in day in day out that will make a
difference
so it's all about disciplines habits
yeah and it's a book that you know what
in all honesty it's a book that
i know when someone reads they're going
to pass it down right
it's one of those books you read it and
it gets you thinking
it's a thinking book so i did the audio
book for it as well last week
and when i was reading it i was like
damn that's good
i was like i know someone's gonna read
that yeah yeah
listen to it like yeah and it's true
it's a thinking book
i ask you what your why is so if i say
to you what what is your why
why is it that you want to train
i've been over this a lot but uh i mean
like
the thing that i keep trying to get my
myself away from is
having a really extrinsic why that's
like i want to look good for summer
because when summer ends and i look good
that [ __ ] is done there we go
that's a lot of people's why's yeah i
want to lose weight for my wedding dress
i want to lose weight for this for an
occasion occasion occasionally yeah
timeline timeline yeah
the occasion comes what then you fall
off a cliff yeah
it's not a sustainable why so i teach
you how to gain a sustainable why which
is fundamentally the most important
foundation you need for fitness
then i teach you habits you don't think
twice about brushing your teeth why
think
twice about your health why think twice
about your health your health is the
most
fundamental and important thing you need
to live
you need to get one of them as well and
why are you thinking twice about it
why are you viewing fitness as a chore
you're viewing your health as a chore
that's a shame your body deserves more
whenever you've heard people speak about
health like this
in a society where women are driven by
fat loss pills
and quick quick fad diets and
intense workout sessions
it's time to stop it's time to tell you
that you need to calm the [ __ ] down
remember your why remember how important
your health is
and understand that if you have a bad
day it's okay
it's okay to have a bad day so that's
what
do this for you is all about it sounds
amazing i'm gonna read it thank you
um we'll we'll link the pre-order as
well in all of the in the podcast and
also on the youtube video i wanted to
ask you what other things you're working
on i
know you just launched a an active wear
line that looks pretty
awesome they are god has so many issues
with that to begin with
but we got there in the end got there in
the end honor active
um honor active is
fundamentally i was actually building
the mission and the vision
for it last week um and
one of the things i said is that i don't
want it to be a trendsetter
why because i don't i don't want
my brand to be something that people
just kind of like buy because it's
trendy and that's that
i want on active to be something you go
back to time and time again
so all of our collections have certain
names like the first collection is
called classic
because you're always going to come back
to it it's designed with specific
material that you always come back to it
the next collection is called timeless
and then our winter collection is called
effortless
so it's designed to have a concept that
it's your best friend
always and forever that it doesn't
matter what year it is you're still
going to love
honor active because trendsetters they
come
and they go you have your 15 minutes
fame and then it goes
yeah but i want something to be
sustainable if you look at nike
lululemon the biggest brands in the
world
they don't have fancy stuff some of the
best
lululemon leggings are the most simplest
ones you'll ever find but they're
trusted
and they're loved and that's exactly
what i want honor to be i'm not here to
start trends
sorry i'm not here to start trends i'm
here to
ensure that you pick up your leggings
and you trust this product
that's my goal for honor active on to
the next business
no toner sculpture toner scott was still
like obviously my
number one baby in an honor active of
course but
what we done with toner sculpt um we
launched a brand new athlete danielle
wilson
i don't know i i clicked on her profile
she followed me i was quite uh
she loves you oh my gosh she's going to
be so excited yeah she's like oh my god
she always reposted and i was like yeah
he's all right
i'm joking she's like oh
but now she is very special
um because i approached her
and the reason why i want to talk about
her briefly in this in this podcast is
because i think it's very important
she's a 200 pound african-american woman
5 foot 11 not your average fitness guru
right
so why would tone and sculpt want her
she's not your average fitness guru why
would you want
someone who women are scared
to think that's what fitness looks like
let me tell you why because fitness
for such a long time is not about the
way it looks
it's about the way it makes you feel she
trains because it makes her feel alive
she's an athlete yeah she trains
athletes
she is an athlete built like an athlete
that's what i wanted for my brand so
when
i approached a year and a half ago i
slid into her dms
and i was like i am every day inspired
by you
and i didn't really think i wanted
trainers other trainers on the tone and
sculpt out but i what i need you i need
you and on this app
and she was like what are you serious
like you really
think i should be on the app and i was
like hell yeah you need to be on this
app
you inspire me i know you're gonna
inspire thousands of other women
and it's funny because when the whole
black lives
matter thing happened five other
companies approached her in that month
five other fitness brands and i had a
face time with her
and i said listen babe if they're
offering you more money
and you think it's a better opportunity
for you i understand
business is business she goes hell no
i'm married to you
i'm not going anywhere i'm married to
you she goes but
how funny is it that it took something
happening
for them to approach me
i didn't say anything and i said to her
i'm gonna let you answer that question
yourself
for yourself oh that that oh that week
my emails were blowing right up black
lives matter week i had
more speaking requests more invitations
to campaigns than i've ever had in my
entire life
you know what it is but i'm gonna be
honest i'm gonna take the bag
do you know what i mean yeah if you're
if you're approaching me because
um you think you suddenly have had this
revelation that you need a black person
involved
fine fine i can't find uh
you know what we're gonna do say no and
then like they're gonna go have to go
because in this case
to find someone else yeah they're not
and in this country when you think about
young black successful entrepreneurs
and jamal edwards there's the guy who
made sbtv who's been on this podcast
it's [ __ ] no one else like that are
you gonna have to start looking at
footballers
if you want young black and successful
and and so yeah
[ __ ] and also i can use that platform
as as a way to
inspire other people to change their
opinions in the same way obama
inspired a lot of naive americans to
think that oh my god a black person can
be smart
and intelligent and clean don't please i
could just so yeah i took the bags every
single bag
all mine and you know what i i'll keep
taking them yeah
no hell yeah hell oh yeah
like are you [ __ ] joking me i said i
i looked at danny i said sanya on the
on the facetime it doesn't matter where
you go it matters what you're going to
represent
yeah yeah do you understand that you're
going to change a
young girl's life by being somewhere
being present being
vocal being ambitious do it if the
platform that's offering you more money
is bigger do it she was like no i want
to be at toner school
of course because you yeah but that's
just loyalty that's just her being loyal
but
it goes beyond bringing another trainer
onto the app
it's about representation it's about i'm
sick and tired of fitness having
one status quo fitness is not one status
quo it's about to help people mentally
and physically
if it wasn't for fitness i would not be
alive today and that's facts
so what's next for chrissy what's next
when you think about the future
personally i don't know business
amazing yeah stuff that are coming up
beyond um but from a personal
perspective i don't know
i really don't know i don't know what's
even happening tomorrow in my personal
life
are you happy in what sense that's the
question
for what in one sense in your life are
you happy
um i would say i'm really happy in my
career
and i'm really happy in my community
um from a personal perspective i think i
need to just
take a breather and i would say i need
to work on my happiness on a personal
perspective a little bit more yeah for
sure
you're gonna do that
see you're funny because you asked me
the questions and you ask if i'm going
to do it and then i don't know the
answer to that question because i don't
know if i will do it
so i don't know i think i just need to
i think i just need to be a bit more
patient with myself and a little bit
kinder to myself
and less self-defensive
listen um i've i've taken a lot of your
time and it's been a fascinating
conversation i've learned a lot about
myself as well
really yeah it's like you know on many
of these issues they are
they're issues that anybody in the
situation
you know both me and you find ourselves
in in life where we're running
businesses and we're very busy but then
we're also trying to
fulfill all of our personal needs at the
same time when one of those you know
facets of our life is so all-consuming
we feel the same things
and we're confused by it we don't have
the answers and
as much as we want to have the answers
and have control over everything because
we are
used to that and we strive for that in
our business you know sometimes we have
to relinquish control in order to be
happy
maybe that's a lot of the answer but
thank you so much for
giving me your time today but more
importantly for giving me so much
honesty
um and where can where can people
find you i mean you're everywhere so
don't ask questions
like you know you've got your book
coming out you've got your app you've
got your activewear line
i'm sure people will find you and um i
just want to say thank you because
there's very few people out there that
are a willing to be honest
it takes a certain vulnerability to be
that honest but it does so much for so
many people
and um on behalf of your community on
behalf of entrepreneurs like me on
behalf of
all of the aspiring female entrepreneurs
that are following in your footsteps a
huge thank you because what you're doing
it's costing you a lot but it's giving
the world even more
so thank you thank you so much
oh
you